as the united states has taken
unprecedented measures to control the
corona virus pandemic including business
closures social distancing measures and
shutdowns across all areas of the
economy the labor market has suffered
unbelievable losses in the month of
April the unemployment rate shot up to
fourteen point seven percent as the
American economy ground to a halt with
twenty point five million jobs
eliminated
that's nearly every job created over the
last decade gone in a single month that
means that April's unemployment rate is
far in a way the worst this country has
seen since the Great Depression the
leisure and hospitality sectors saw the
biggest losses with more than seven
million jobs lost the retail industry
which has seen a number of high-profile
bankruptcies this month saw more than 2
million losses so far more than 33
million people have filed for
unemployment benefits over the last
seven weeks that's more than 10 percent
of the population of the United States
and more than the entire population of
the state of Texas just two months ago
the unemployment rate was sitting at
3.5% a 50-year low and losses are
starting to bleed into other areas of
the economy which could point to a
longer slower recovery finance and
professional services jobs have been
eliminated as have construction and
manufacturing jobs even the gig economy
hasn't been exempt Airbnb has cut 25% of
its workforce about 1900 employees uber
announced that it will lay off 3700
workers and lyft eliminated 17 percent
of its workforce almost a thousand
people last week another 3.2 million
people filed for unemployment benefits
and while the weekly pace of these
claims are slowing these are some of the
worst numbers we've ever seen as
millions of Americans each week file new
unemployment claims state systems are
unable to keep up many people aren't
even able to get through meaning that
this data is likely under reporting the
full scope of the
lawmakers return to Washington this week
to hash out the prospect of sending more
federal aid to state and local
governments the 2.2 trillion dollar
cares Act allocated a hundred and fifty
billion for direct aid to States but
many officials have said that amount
won't be nearly enough to cover the
costs and revenue shortfalls associated
with the coronavirus crisis
[Music]
you